-(AUDIENCE CHEERING, APPLAUDING)
-Okay, welcome to Overtime.
We're here
with Minnesota congressman
and 2024 Democratic
presidential candidate,
Dean Phillips.
Host of Fareed Zakaria GPS
on CNN, Fareed Zakaria.
And president of Eurasia Group
and GZERO Media, Ian Bremmer.
Here are the questions,
I'm rushing
'cause I gotta get to Vegas.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
-This is for you, Congressman.
"Who would you choose
to be your running mate?"
Oh, good question.
I didn't ask you that.
Oh, I have to choose
a different person now?
-Uh. Well, your running mate.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
-My running mate?
-Yeah.
It's way too early for that.
I will surprise you,
I promise you that.
-Meaning? I don't--
-I will surprise you.
I will absolutely surprise you
with a running mate.
FAREED ZAKARIA:
Good surprise or bad surprise?
-Good surprise.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
-BILL MAHER: Yeah, that's...
-Well--
It almost sounded like a threat.
(CHUCKLES)
-I promise you.
-Really?
-I will surprise you.
-It's not Carrot Top, is it?
-(FAREED CHUCKLING)
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, CHEERING)
-(CHUCKLES) Carrot Top--
-All right.
-Carrot--
-I love him, but I don't know.
No, Carrot Top
had too high demands.
-All right.
-I mean, I can't give away--
I can't give away
this stuff so early.
-I know you want an answer,
I'm sorry.
-All right, did Democrats, uh,
make a strategic error
by not saving Kevin McCarthy
now that we're stuck
with a much more extreme
Speaker of the House?
That's an interesting question.
-Well, there really is--
-They could have, right?
There's a danger of a really...
I mean,
you were alluding to this.
Of a real political
constitutional crisis
'cause right,
Trump is gonna be the nominee.
So, one of two things
are gonna happen in 2024.
He's either gonna win,
that has its own problems,
-or he's gonna claim he won.
-DEAN PHILLIPS: Exactly.
-Those are the only two options.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
-BILL: Absolutely.
-Right?
BILL:
I've said it for seven years.
-Right. And--
-But he's gonna show up...
-But this time--
-...Inauguration Day,
-January 2025, he will show up.
-But this time,
say the Pennsylvania state
legislature,
where the laws, I think,
have been changed,
where they can send
an alternate, uh,
slate of electors,
and who do they send them to?
-The Speaker of the House.
-DEAN: Mm-hmm. Exactly.
-Mike Johnson. Who is--
-BILL: Right.
Who is gonna be very willing
-to hear all the stuff...
-BILL: Right.
...that at least Kevin McCarthy
-in the crunch...
-BILL: Right.
-DEAN: And let me tell you guys.
-You know?
It's important
everybody know this.
We extended
a number of overtures
to Speaker McCarthy,
a number of other Republicans,
saying we wanna work together.
Just make
some modest concessions.
First of all,
make the House work,
that was our first demand.
Not one of them
would speak to us
because they knew
if they actually attracted
a single Democratic vote,
-let alone ten, 15, 20...
-Right.
...that they
would be eviscerated
by their brothers and sisters
on their side.
That is the culture of Congress
that is absolutely destroying
the country.
IAN BREMMER:
That's the culture of the House.
-The culture of the House.
-Yes, not the Senate.
DEAN: But no, it's not--
That is true, not the Senate.
But that is the truth.
I heard you say before
when we were talking that,
you know, you're gonna stop this
and we gotta work together.
Everybody says that.
What's the plan?
-What's the plan to do that?
-Well, the plan is--
You just said they wouldn't even
fucking talk to you.
-IAN: What?
-I--
-What's the plan?
-No, no.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
-Oh, no. No, no.
-FAREED: Well, it begins--
-No, let me--
It begins
with the surprise running mate.
-Yes, that-- It begins with--
No, let me--
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
(ALL LAUGHING)
-I mean it. Look, as--
-Dick Cheney?
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
-IAN: You said all parties.
-I was the most
bipartisan member of Congress...
-IAN: Team of rivals.
...last year,
the second most this year.
I really do, I love my brothers
and sisters on both sides.
There are
some wonderful Republicans,
who I think have a chance
to rise,
I think want to work together.
This wasn't the time to do it,
but wish to do so
and there are some outstanding--
But again,
how do you liberate them
-from this problem
you're talking about...
-I'll tell you why.
-...where they're afraid to.
-That's why I'm running-- Look,
I'm running for president
to win.
I believe we can.
I believe it's time
for a new generation.
-Does anybody agree, by the way?
-(AUDIENCE CHEERING, APPLAUDING)
And-- And...
You know, the last time
in American history
that I think a president
really accomplished the notion
of a team of rivals
was Abe Lincoln.
And I do think it's time,
I really do believe it's time
for a Democratic president
to ensure that there
are conservative voices
in the White House,
within the Cabinet,
uh, having his or her ear,
and vice versa.
It should go the other way
as well. I'll do so.
And I think so that's why
running for president,
you can actually break
this gridlock by actually...
-I think I know
what the surprise is.
-...engaging conservatives.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, CHEERING)
-IAN: Yeah?
-Oh, no, no. I didn't say that.
-No, no, no.
But you're hinting
that you would have
your team of rivals,
somebody else...
Oh, absolutely,
in the White House.
...so that your vice president
would be...
No, I'm not saying I am.
I'm saying
I would not rule that out.
IAN: You're saying you might.
You're sort of teasing it.
-You're saying you might.
-BILL: Just say it, just say it.
-It's Ramaswamy.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, CHEERING)
All right. That, I-- That...
I think I can promise you.
It ain't--
-It ain't Ramaswamy.
-But somebody like-- But, like--
All right, so we won't say
it's your VP.
But, like, who are some of
the more reasonable Republicans
who, if that was the direction
you were going into,
-you would choose from.
-Well first of all,
I think we lost two of
our great, young conservatives
in Anthony Gonzalez,
uh, Pete Meijer.
They had the audacity to vote
to impeach Trump, ten of them.
Nine of them got thrown out
of the House essentially.
I will tell you
that Dusty Johnson,
uh, a very principled,
good person--
-Dusty Johnson?
-Dusty Johnson.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
-Who's that?
-(CHUCKLES)
-DEAN: See? You don't know.
-That's--
-I don't know. I thought he--
I thought he was some
old Western actor, you know?
-Dusty Johnson. Remember--
-(SPEAKING INDISTINCTLY)
-Remember Dusty Johnson?
-But nobody knows.
-Yeah, no, nobody knows.
-You guys, nobody knows--
-Okay.
-Nobody knows--
He's gonna be
on the show next week. (LAUGHS)
(LAUGHS) Phillips, Johnson,
that's who I'm--
See, if I out my friends,
they're gonna lose their races.
I don't wanna do it.
But very sincerely,
the problem is
they're the work horses,
not the show horses,
so you don't know their names.
-BILL: Right.
-You know Lauren Boebert
and Marjorie Taylor Greene...
-BILL: Yes, we do.
-...and Jim Jordan
because they're destructive,
-and I'm tired of it.
-How about Mitt Romney?
-Mitt Romney, he's a gentleman.
-He's a gentleman.
-And he's principled.
-(CHUCKLES)
And he already ran...
-He already ran.
-...and he's a known quantity.
I mean, yes,
a lot of people hate him,
-but, like-- No, but like...
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
-But he stood...
-He stood strong.
He's one of those, what I call,
"As good
as it gets Republicans."
Liz Cheney, Liz--
I sat with Liz Cheney...
-Ah, they hate her.
-...on January 6th.
-They don't hate Mitt as much.
-They hate principle right now
and it's a shame.
Liz Cheney had principles,
she got thrown out of the House.
I was with her on January 6th,
when she looked
at the television screen,
Donald Trump on it.
-She said, "He's responsible."
-BILL: Right.
"We're gonna hold him
to account."
The whole room erupted.
Democrats and Republicans.
A year later, look who was left.
-Very few.
-So, okay last question.
RFK is leading among, I read,
young people and independents
and in a three-way race, uh,
he gets now, like,
-higher than, like--
-Twenty-two percent,
-apparently, in the last one.
-He gets 22. I mean,
that's pretty amazing,
what do you think?
Yeah, but he takes more
from Trump, all right?
-BILL: Takes more from Trump.
-Takes more from Trump, and,
you know, I mean,
he's sort of dominating
the conspiracy theory lane,
which is a lane now
in US politics.
Um, and if he continues to run
as opposed to, like,
the No Labels,
Joe Manchin fever dream,
which I think
was never going to happen.
Um, then it actually gives Biden
more of a shot,
and at the end of the day,
if good Dean Phillips
doesn't somehow make it
to take Biden out,
um, then you're gonna need
to have Biden be able to do it
and a third-party candidate
may actually help on that front.
I mean, the fundamental problem,
why all of these scenarios
are terrifying,
is we don't actually have
a real election, right?
I mean, Biden will win
probably by nine million votes,
-but the most powerful man--
-BILL: Biden will?
-Right.
-IAN: Popular votes.
-Against Trump?
-Popular vote, right?
-It doesn't mean anything?
-He won by--
He won by seven
and a half last time.
Oh, I'm glad you're so sanguine
about that. I am not.
But what I'm not sanguine
about is--
BILL: He could totally lose.
No, but-- but even if--
If I didn't think he
was gonna lose, I wouldn't be
all in for Dean Phillips.
-You're not listening.
-(AUDIENCE APPLAUDING, CHEERING)
Dean Phillips,
I've said it for years.
(FAREED LAUGHING)
For God's sake. Please.
-And if not him, Dusty Johnson.
-Get behind Phillips. Okay.
No, but the point is,
it's gonna be decided
in four states, right?
I mean, the Electoral College
-is what matters.
-BILL: Yeah. Yes.
Biden will win the popular vote,
-the problem is...
-BILL: You don't know that.
...four states, Pennsylvania,
-Arizona, Georgia, Wisconsin.
-He'll win the popular vote.
-Doesn't matter.
-And you're probably--
And he's down
in each of them, guys.
-Yeah. Yeah.
-He's down in each
of the battleground states
right now.
That's one reason
I'm doing this.
We have to do this.
-The alternative is disastrous.
-Okay, I gotta go to Vegas.
-Thank you very much everybody.
-(AUDIENCE CHEERING, APPLAUDING)